was there almost a plan for a new actor
to play t'challa after Chadwick
boseman's tragic death 2020 saw the
tragic passing of Chadwick Boseman the
t'challa actor died from colon cancer
months before black panther wakanda
forever was set to begin production
in light of the tragedy Marvel Studios
postponed the highly anticipated sequel
giving the casting crew time to grieve
over The Late actor and decide on next
steps director Ryan coogler and Marvel
Cinematic Universe architect Kevin feige
ultimately decided not to recast the
role of t'challa a decision that led to
mixed reception from some fans he was
King and black panther to everyone while
some fans petition the studio to recast
the king of wakanda Marvel VP of
development Nate Moore made it very
clear t'challa will not be seen on
screen again out of respect for Bozeman
he revealed on the ringer verse podcast
in November 2021 months after wakanda
forever had started production when Chad
passed it was a real conversation we had
with director Ryan coogler about what do
we do and it was a fast conversation it
wasn't weeks it was minutes of we had to
figure out how to move that franchise
arm without that character because I
think we all feel so much of t'challa
and the MCU on the screen is tied to
Chadwick's performance the marketing for
wakanda forever has directly confirmed
that t'challa has passed in Universe
though which remains to be seen how
coogler and co-writer Joe Robert Cole
tackle it scrapping away the original
idea for the Black Panther sequel may
have been difficult but from the Rave
social media reactions wakanda from
forever has received it seems that
coogler has delivered another winner but
while more emphasized how quickly the
decision had to be made Ryan coogler has
confirmed that he considered recasting
t'challa at one point the director
recently appeared on Marvel Studios
wakanda forever the official black
panther podcast to discuss the sequel
the nearly 40-minute long chat dived
deep into the world of wakanda how the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has evolved
and how Chadwick boseman's death
influenced and changed the sequel the
conversation eventually led to the
director being asked to discuss her
significance and responsibility of a new
actor taking on the role of black
panther Kugler candidly replied you
consider everything when something like
that happens it's like I don't think I
can come back and make another one I
don't think I can do this I don't think
there should be another one you go
through all of the extremes getting
emotional coogler confirmed that
recasting was considered an option
before opening up about why the thought
of recasting dissipated and at all boils
down to being honest and seeking out the
truth he continued by opening up about
how his job as a director is to spend
hundreds of days convincing his casting
crew to believe in ideas that he finds
truthful I have to believe in something
enough to go convince other
professionals to believe in it as well
for an extended period of time expanding
on that sentiment Kugler explained how
his responsibility is to weed out
anything in the film or creative that
screams quote nope to him I have to have
a Fighting Chance of putting something
out in front of the audience that the
audience can believe in and not be taken
out of for two hours they have to
believe in some kernel of truth that's
happening on the screen in the pursuit
of his truth which shaped wakanda
forever Kugler was clear about one thing
Chadwick's gone from the physical sense
he wasn't working through that door he
was the guy Kugler recognized that if he
himself didn't believe in the idea of
recasting t'challa there was no truth in
his vision for somebody else to be him
for us in the world that we created we
wouldn't have believed it no matter how
good the actor was it would have been
lacking the necessary Truth for us to do
a good job it sounds like the idea of
seriously recasting Bozeman's iconic
role wasn't the path that coogler was
interested in going down the writer
director had some more fond words for
the dearly departed actor saying Our
Truth was lost which is a fact of life
it's the gift and the curse of Life
Heroes Great Men die